[Música]
en el día 14 de la invasión de rusia a
ucrania continúan los ataques y
bombardeos a varias ciudades ucranianas
pero hoy luego de varios intentos
fallidos se lleva a cabo de forma segura
por el momento la evacuación de los
civiles a través de seis corredores
humanitarios al margen de esta
evacuación de los civiles que finalmente
parece exitosa siguen por su parte las
acusaciones de rusia a ucrania con el
fin de justificar su invasión en las
últimas horas moscú aseguró que ucrania
planeaba un ataque decisivo en la región
del donbass y además denunció a ucrania
que estaba trabajando en armas
biológicas cerca de las fronteras rusas
como el ántrax o la peste con el apoyo
de eeuu algo que washington calificó
como absurdo y para ello entonces
saludamos a paulo potala es el director
del programa ejecutivo en medio oriente
contemporáneo de la universidad católica
argentina gracias pablo por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
esta evacuación de los civiles jamás
centrarnos en esto porque se tardaron
tanto las partes para establecer los
corredores humanitarios seguros y que
realmente se preparan
se está realizando el cese del fuego en
este momento
bien bueno creo que hay hay varias
formas de verlo en un primer lugar
obviamente que hay una necesidad
humanitaria estamos hablando de ámbitos
urbanos donde la mayoría de la población
son no combatientes y además que son los
que están por otra parte pasan llevando
la peor parte en este conflicto entonces
en ese sentido hay una necesidad
humanitaria pero no debemos dejar de
lado una necesidad de carácter militar
en un contexto donde las fuerzas rusas
están rodeando las ciudades más
importantes pues sacar a los civiles es
el primer paso para cualquier operación
militar puesto que una vez que los
civiles
ya no están en el ámbito urbano pues es
posible llevar adelante operaciones de
carácter militar por tanto porque yo
diría es esa la necesidad humanitaria lo
cual es es lo que nos lo cual estamos
viendo pero también en el fondo esto
también obedece a una necesidad de
carácter militar por lo tanto no podemos
pensar que con esta salida de civiles se
va a terminar el conflicto sí porque tal
vez podría en algunos casos operarse
y este este conflicto pues trata
occidente casi que todos los días no de
presionar más al presidente ruso
vladimir putin para que no siga con su
ofensiva militar a ucrania más sanciones
vemos hoy de la unión europea pero vemos
que no está teniendo el efecto que ellos
quieren el efecto necesario para que el
presidente vladimir putin diga el paro
la guerra y por un momento vamos a
sentarnos a negociar con un cese al
fuego total por qué ocurre esto porque
estas sanciones no son tan efectivas en
las decisiones de vladimir putin
yo creo que no es que no sean efectivas
todo el mundo coincide en que una trae
un efecto devastador en la economía rusa
en su
prestigio en el sistema internacional lo
que pasa es que la rapidez el efecto de
las sanciones y la rapidez de las
operaciones militares son dos
velocidades
las operaciones militares para decirlo
de una manera van ahora mucho más rápida
sobre el terreno que el impacto que
puede tener las sanciones que lo van a
tener alguna vez y ya lo están teniendo
en la economía rusa por lo tanto creo
que son dos niveles distintos son dos
velocidades
en las operaciones militares no podemos
pensar que las sanciones pueden tener un
efecto inmediato en realidad las
sanciones están orientadas a modificar
el comportamiento político
y detener esta acción digital de la
alteración de rusia
y la federación denuncia en este momento
está tratando de mantener la presión de
manera tal de encontrar una solución
diplomática que refleje sus objetivos
-pablo entonces también le quería
preguntar si estas sanciones económicas
y todo esto que estamos viendo en rusia
afecta a los civiles y con esta
afectación de los civiles se pudiera
generar como algún tipo también de
presión por parte de ellos hacia el
gobierno ruso realmente esto pudiera
pasar viendo por supuesto también la
represión que hemos visto en las calles
a estos ciudadanos que rechazan la
guerra cientos de arrestados miles de
arrestados
es difícil es difícil pensar que va a
haber a cortísimo plazo una presión de
vida de los propios ciudadanos rusos
hacia el gobierno de 300 rusos para
modificar este comportamiento hoy por
hoy con los elementos que tenemos
estándar el exterior creemos es bueno
que no es algo que sea inmediato pero en
eso no significa que no queden sembradas
las semillas de un descontento que puede
tener un impacto político a mediano oa
largo plazo también hablamos de la
ciudad portuaria de mariupol que está
sellada por estas tropas rusas ellos
aseguran tener víveres para aguantar
tres días más digamos que en todo este
bloqueo según dijo un diputado ucraniano
que va a pasar cuando se empiecen a
acabar entonces estos insumos de
alimentos de aguas en estas ciudades y
todavía ahí continúan los civiles
pues esa es la lógica militar la lógica
militar es no ingresar a un ámbito
urbano donde es muy difícil para unos
pues una fuerza militar que quiera tomar
esa ciudad de respecto un enorme
esfuerzo y por lo tanto la práctica rusa
para hacia dónde lo estamos bien nos
rodean las ciudades así y armas ya
lograr el objetivo político sin emplear
en términos urbanos el
instrumento de carácter militar pues en
el objetivo ruso es claramente que esas
ciudades caigan bajo control que es así
que es políticamente eso significó una
tardía para el presidente primero
shilinsky pero en realidad que eso se
haga de una manera digamos
sin utilizar los medios los medios
militares entran dentro de las ciudades
pues lo que vamos a ver que creo que es
y si estos pasos se desmayó con
probablemente sea la misma actuar
pablo también rusia ha acusado a ucrania
para justificar digamos su invasión a
ese país ha dicho que se están
supuestamente fabricando armas
biológicas en a la frontera ucraniana
con rusia también sacaron unos
documentos que todavía están por
verificarse todas estas acusaciones que
hace moscú a kiev de una operación que
haría el gobierno ucraniano para este
mes de marzo en el donbass que hay que
hay sobre esto porque rusia digamos está
haciendo este tipo de acusaciones que
más pretende eso es para justificar
digamos esa ofensiva y luego del retiro
de los civiles la evacuación de los
civiles de esas de sociedades arremeter
como fuerza
miren todo conflicto que será lo que se
denomina la niebla de guerra y nunca
todo lo que se ve es ciento por ciento
cierto hay un enorme cantidad de
justificaciones al enorme cantidad de
información es menos articulada de esta
idea de los técnicos se convierte en un
instrumento de propaganda para las
partes
por supuesto que todas estas ecuaciones
del gobierno ruso no son gratuitas todas
tienen por objetivo último justificar el
ataque contra ucrania y que en este
sentido creo que están más orientadas
hacia una
segura audiencia interna doméstica que
hacia el ámbito exterior pues pablo
gracias por su tiempo por su análisis
por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 un abrazo
ahora son muchísimas gracias gracias a
ti paula estamos conversando con pablo
botta director del programa ejecutivo en
medio oriente con temporario de la
iglesia católica en argentina esto es
directo américa
[Música]